bruno daroux ya des discussions pour
envoyer des avions de guerre à l'ukraine
à partir de la pologne déclaration ce
matin dans tony blinken qu'on a pu
suivre sur france 24 est ce qu'il ya un
risque d'escaladé ce que les occidentaux
peuvent vont rester neutre sur le plan
aérien alors c'est justement on
entendait à l'instant la meilleure
poutine qui disait qu'une zone
d'exclusion aérienne ça ce serait
considéré comme un cas de kobe liger ans
donc c'est pour essayer de contourner
cet obstacle puisque l'otan a dit il n'y
aura pas effectivement de zone
d'exclusion aérienne donc comment
contourner l'obstacle comme en répondant
aux demandes du président zelensky qui
demande notamment qu'on lui confie des
avions et bien c'est à quoi les
occidentaux sont en train de réfléchir
et les amériques et affectivement donc
propose à la pologne donc 2 voilà on
voit là tous les pays membres de l'otan
mais c'est bien sûr ces pays là le plus
particulièrement qui nous intéresse donc
ils sont en train de discuter avec les
polonais pour que les polonais en fait
fournissent à à l'armée ukrainienne
des avions de fabrication aux russes
qu'ils ont déjà en leur possession et
les américains du coup fournir à la
pologne des f 16 américains alors
pourquoi parce que zelensky a dit aux
pays d'europe de l'est donnez moi des
avions mais des avions de fabrication
russe pourquoi parce que nos pilotes
savent les conduire savent les piloter
pardon et que donc de ce point de vue là
ce sera utile ce sera immédiatement
opérationnel alors après comment
l'annuaire poutine si tout cela se fait
va-t-il réagir il peut considérer
effectivement que c'est une forme d'acte
de guerre de la part de pays de l'otan
qui fournissent donc à l'armée que
donnent les moyens de se défendre les
occidentaux peuvent répondre mais nous
fournissons déjà d'autres types d'armes
à l'ukraine mais évidemment fournir des
avions de chasse à l'armée ukrainienne
ce serait considéré comme l'un des
meilleures poutines comme une forme
d'agression plus direct on va dire parce
que évidemment l'objectif des ukrainiens
c'est de casser le monopole que
l'aviation russe a sur le ciel ukrainien
et qui lui permet de bombarder les les
grandes villes du pays alors justement
sur le terrain pour revenir au terrain
crenn y compris chez les ukrainiens
russophone il semble que le sentiment
anti poutine soit aujourd'hui dominant
oui alors c'est une évolution qu on
avait déjà observé au cours des
dernières années mais enfin qui devient
très fort et ça ça peut être préoccupant
pour le moyen et le long terme pour les
russes qui donc on l'a dit on
établissait une forme de corridors qui
part du donbass qui qui longe la crimée
qui ira peut-être même jusqu'à odessa
parce que ce sont là c'est là que réside
l'essentiel de la population russophone
d'ukraine mais vu l'ampleur de
l'agression et la brutalité de
l'agression on pense notamment
évidemment à ce qui se passe en ce
moment à marioupol ou à kharkiv qui est
aussi majoritairement russophone est
bien le sentiment national et tentera si
vous voulez de l'emporter sur le
sentiment au culturel d'appartenance à
l'univers russe on va dire et donc ça
c'est un phénomène assez marquant c'est
que même dans ses parties de l'est et du
sud du pays les ukrainiens russophone
sont en train de devenir on va dire 100%
ukrainien et sont en train de 2,2 de ne
pas comprendre que vladimir poutine
puisse leur faire ça et donc ça
développe forcément un sentiment
antirusse très fort merci beaucoup